In this lecture, we
introduce the
notion of a random variable.
A random variable is, loosely
speaking, a numerical quantity
whose value is determined by the
outcome of a probabilistic
experiment.
The weight of a randomly
selected
student is one example.
After giving a general
definition, we will focus
exclusively on discrete
random variables.
These are random variables that
take values in finite or
countably infinite sets.
For example, random variables
that take
integer values are discrete.
To any discrete random variable
we will associate a
probability mass function, which
tells us the likelihood
of each possible value of
the random variable.
Then we will go over a few
examples and introduce some
common types of random
variables.
And finally we will introduce
a new concept- the expected
value of the random variable,
also called the
expectation or mean.
It is a weighted average of
the values of the random
variable, weighted according
to their respective
probabilities, and has an
intuitive interpretation as
the average value we expect to
see if we repeat the same
probabilistic experiment
independently a
large number of times.
Expected values play a central
role in probability theory.
We will look into some
of their properties.
And we will also calculate the
expected values of the example
random variables that we
will have introduced.